Uh, this is one of those funny stories about
the pot calling the kettle black that reflects
the total blind hyper partisanship.
That is one of the most toxic elements of
politics today.
Donald Trump jr is calling out the Bidens
for nepotism.
It sounds like stat tire.
It sounds like an onion article.
Now I don't want to redo this because I've
already done it.
Um, I've not ignored the totally toxic nature
of the political status quo.
That leads to someone like Hunter Biden, Joe
Biden's son, to have a $50,000 a month consulting
contract with a Ukrainian gas company.
I did an entire story about this last week
or the week before.
There is no question that this is exactly
the type of thing that is endemic to our political
system.
It's the revolving door of elected officials
and lawyers and lobbyists and consultants,
including both themselves and their family
members and their significant others.
We need to root it out.
It's a problem.
There is no question.
Now that being said, there was nothing particularly
egregious about the Hunter Biden consulting
gig in the sense that Trump has have been
arguing the conspiratorial way.
This is the system we have.
It's a disgusting system.
It's a corrupt system.
It has to be changed, but it's business as
usual.
But then Donald Trump jr goes on Twitter and
says, Biden's career Hunter Biden's career
is based just on his dad's and that's bad
and that's corrupt.
His name is Donald Trump jr. and he's saying
that the name Biden being a Biden has put
Hunter Biden in a privileged position.
Has irony died.
Take a look at this video clip from the Sean
Hannity program.
A very rehearsed Donald Trump jr trying to
make this case
when you're the father and your son's entire
career is dependent on that.
They own you Sean.
That's what it is.
They've bought Biden inc and they've been
doing it both domestically, whether it was
MBNA bank, whether it was Amtrak, whatever
it was domestically when he was a Senator
and had influence over domestic policy and
they started doing it internationally.
The second Joe Biden became vice president
and had authority abroad.
Donald Trump
jr is criticizing someone else for having
a career built on their name and their father's
name.
So there are two options here.
One is that Don jr is genuinely so dumb that
he just doesn't realize that his critique
of Joe and Hunter Biden is relevant 10 times
over about him and Eric Trump and Ivanka Trump
in relation to Donald Trump senior, the president
of the United States.
That's one possibility.
The other possibility is he does get it, but
he assumes Sean Hannity's audience and his
dad's followers are so dumb that they won't
notice the obvious hypocrisy of him.
Donald Trump jr criticizing Joe and Hunter
Biden of nepotism.
The funny thing is that this is actually something
that Don jr is an authority on.
You know, I said last week we covered Leora
Trump, who's the wife of Eric Trump being
brought onto Fox news to comment on Syria.
What does Lera Trump know about Syria and
the Kurds?
Absolutely nothing.
Don jr actually is an expert on nepotism and
how to use your father's name to get money
and speaking gigs and build a career.
He's done it.
He is the right person to be commenting about
it.
The problem is he's commenting about it as
if it's a problem he's observing rather than
something he's an example of.
And of course that irony is not lost on many
of the leftists who have seen what has gone
on here.
Hundred Biden was paid $50,000 a month to
consult for a Ukrainian gas company.
Is that a gig he would have had if he wasn't
Joe Biden son?
Of course not.
Donald Trump, jr is making millions from the
presidency of his father is in a privileged
and powerful position where he more Ivanka
Trump, they're meeting with world leaders.
There's sometimes sitting in for their dad
who is the president of the United States.
Would they have that if they weren't Donald
Trump's son?
Obviously not.
And this is a complete lack of self-awareness
made even more cartoonish by the fact that
his name is literally the same name as his
dad, right?
Hunter Biden, Joe Biden, Donald Trump, Donald
Trump, jr.
If having the same last name as a former vice
president is lucrative.
What about having just literally the same
name as the current president of the United
States?
My question to you is, and I don't know the
answer to this, is Don jr dumb enough that
he doesn't realize the irony of what he's
saying or is he smart enough to realize it,
but he just thinks the people watching Sean
Hannity are too stupid to figure it out?
Let me know by either commenting on this video
on YouTube or by sending me a tweet at D Pacman.
We will take a quick break and be back after
this to talk about the best thing that has
ever happened to Tulsi Gabbert.
Okay.
If you've been paying attention to the news
over the last few days, maybe you know what
it is.
It relates to Hillary Clinton that's coming
up next